this sleep disorder machine has a new
function treating coronavirus developed
at Leeds University it slowly blows air
into the throat via a mask and that
means that the patient stays awake will
avoid the drugs to keep them asleep they
were able to bleed from himself to be
able to communicate they were able to
still interact with their loved ones
were possible and we thought that the
time they spent needing support was less
this kind of ventilation is being used
clinically at Warrington Hospital it's
hoped the machines could prevent
patients needing more invasive
mechanical ventilation and that's a
relief for many why didn't you want to
go on a ventilator but should more
patients be treated this way politicians
aren't ruling it out the clinical
practice how people are treated by the
doctors has been changing throughout
this as we've learnt from abroad and
then learnt from cases here at home you
know this is a new virus and it has lots
of unusual features the government had
asked engineering firms to help build
thousands of new medical ventilators but
despite fears of a shortage orders are
outstripping the current demand the
company Dyson has been told the
ventilator it developed is no longer
needed and as the virus spreads around
the world clinicians are evaluating
mechanical ventilation there are risks
in intubating a patient too quickly and
that there can be harms both from
mechanical ventilation and from the
drugs that we use to enable mechanical
ventilation but there are also risks in
not integrating quickly enough they if
people come very sick and we intubate
them too late that also can be a problem
so there's quite a finely balanced
judgment some clinicians claim the kind
of respiratory problems Kovac patients
have need gentler ventilation as this
disease advances so too does our
understand
thing of it leaving clinicians
constantly rethinking and re-examining
how best to treat it Laura Bundick Sky
News